this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description the
infamous k1 visa is in the spotlight
thanks the mega popular show the 90-day
fiance and it's apparently never-ending
number of spin-offs like the 90-day
fiance the other way happily ever after
before the 90 days 90 days of facebook
chats say yes to the 90 days we found
love thanks to Google Translate and the
4-hour work fiancee leave it to TLC to
turn a complicated immigration process
into a hit reality show the premise of
the 90-day fiance is that an American
citizen falls in love with someone from
another country once the couple is
engaged US immigration law allows the
fiance to enter the country legally the
process for this is known as the
non-immigrant visa also referred to it
by its formal name the k1 visa obviously
Americans can't get enough of
international relationships in this
video though we're going to be talking
about love marriage and international
travel and the legality of the 90-day
fiance is k1 visa Haley illegals it's
time to think like a lawyer because even
crappy reality TV shows implicate
complex legal issues the fiance
non-immigrant visa is the document an
American citizen needs to bring his or
her foreign fiancee to the United States
the k1 visa permits the foreign citizen
fiance to travel to knighted States and
marry his or her US citizen sponsor
within 90 days of arrival once married
the foreign citizen will then apply for
adjustment of status to lawful permanent
resident can stay in the United States
as long as they like who can get the k1
visa well the first requirement is that
the US citizen and fiance must be
legally allowed to marry at the time of
the petition for the k1 visa was filed
marriage laws differ of course from
country to country and state to state so
to get a k1 visa the marriage has to be
legally possible according to the laws
of the United States and the state in
which the marriage will take place
now the second requirement is that the
couple must have actually met in person
90-day fiance fans often ask whether the
government cares at all about how much
time these people spend with each other
before applying for the k1 and
United States the answer is that
generally the foreign citizen fiance and
the US citizen sponsor must have
actually met in person at least once
within the past two years it's probably
not too much to ask when you think about
it although the US government can grant
an exception to this requirement for
extreme hardship it is extremely rare
for this requirement to be waived we
have seen lots of examples of people not
knowing each other for very long before
applying for the fiancee visa on the
show Robert from the most recent season
of the 90-day fiance probably takes the
cake he met his Dominican fiancee Annie
on Facebook and then scheduled a cruise
to meet her in person and she's hi
Robert then left the cruise for a trip
and spent a whopping eight hours with
her before deciding that this cardi B
look-alike was his dream woman I guess
it was love at first ship their meeting
took slightly less time than it takes to
register a new car at the DMV but guess
what Robert and Annie's quick trip met
the bare minimum requirement for the k1
visa and there have been several couples
who use mobile phone apps to communicate
with each other because neither speaks
the other person's language in hospital
I want to talk about our future but I
think we can all agree that love is the
universal language so how does one apply
for a k1 visa well the application
process is long and it can be very
arduous you need a lot of paperwork to
get the ball rolling including an online
non-immigrant visa application plus
additional forms if the person has
children a passport birth certificate
divorce certificates if applicable
police certificates from everywhere the
fiance has lived since the age of 16
medical examinations photographs
evidence of the relationship and payment
of fees and there's just one more thing
evidence of financial support this is
actually a pretty big deal u.s.
politicians frequently make claims about
the immigration process and that they
worry that people who come to United
States will be a financial burden on the
country but to some extent immigration
laws already have strict requirements
about financial responsibility when you
come to United States during their visa
interview applicants
must produce evidence to the councilor
office that they will not become a
public charge in the United States
public charge refers to being unable to
provide basic necessities of living like
housing food shelter and clothing if a
person will become a public charge the
visa will be denying that person cannot
enter the country now the evidence of
financial support could be information
showing the person can financially
support themselves for instance if the
person has a job lined up or has a
lucrative career as a model or they just
happen to be incredibly rich since this
is likely not the case for most people
they must be able to show that the US
citizen can provide financial support
the American citizen will have to file
an affidavit stating that he or she will
be able to support their new spouse and
any children who come over with that new
fiance this is a legally binding
contract if the person the citizen is
sponsoring becomes a public charge and
the government has to provide public
services the agency providing the help
can sue the American citizen to recover
the costs so how does the US government
decide whether someone will become a
public charge there are many factors a
person's age education work experience
skills assets financial resources and
health they're all taken into account
and we've seen how the allegation of a
public charge possibility has impacted
the somewhat happy couples when Nicole a
single mother who struggles to make ends
meet fell in love with a man from
Morocco she knew she would be unable to
meet the financial requirements of the
k1 visa but her father decided to
co-sponsor Ahsan and the government gave
him a visa I mean he sounded sincere he
sounded like he wants to be with Nicole
he's a good guy and you guys will see
that when you get to me Paul has
appeared on two seasons of 90-day fiance
Paul is a Kentucky man in his late 30s
who fell in love with a Brazilian woman
named Corrine are you excited to meet me
you excited I'm coming to Brazil
no she doesn't understand that's not
good despite their age difference 12
years and language problems neither
speak the other person's language they
fell in love Paul and Corrine first
appeared on before the 90 days which
chronicled Paul's efforts to bring
Corrine to the United States Paul
inquired about bringing Corrine to
America on a k1 visa but he ran into
trouble because he's a grown-ass man
living with his parents who doesn't
really work I'm definitely a mama's boy
I will say that financial affidavit
requires proof of income three years of
tax returns bank statements employee
verification and lots of other stuff
that Paul didn't have and Paul's mom
wasn't about to sign the papers
necessary to support Corrine I think
it's all crazy myself early when Corrine
got pregnant the couple then appeared on
90 day the other way where Paul decided
to go live in careens very remote
brazilian hometown the hapless Paul's
exploits in Brazil included worrying
about whether deadly fish would be able
to swim up his urethra and carrying a
mosquito net with him everywhere better
to have it and not need it than need it
and not have it the relationship might
not have worked but it made for some
fantastic television chickens now one of
the highlights of his storyline was Paul
running into the jungle after the
government of Brazil denied him the
right to live permanently in the country
of Brazil the reason Paul has a felony
conviction for arson the second case my
ex Khurana both took out restraining
orders against each other just a quality
human being and as you can see other
countries also have immigration
standards but love conquers all so that
left the couple back where they started
trying to assure the US government that
Paul can financially support his family
if they come to United States now that
Paul's mom has grandchildren she may be
more willing to sign that financial
affidavit I'm told you should definitely
stay tuned now ninety-day fans are
always on the lookout for people abusing
the fiancee application process is this
true love or just a foreigner looking
for a green card is the American citizen
sketchy and dangling the visa as
leverage to control their foreign fiance
well Congress has long been concerned
the possibility of abuse and fraud and
exploitation from both the US citizen
and the foreign fiance in 2005 Congress
enacted the International marriage
broker Regulation Act to reduce abuse of
marriage based visa recipients the law
adds a few safeguards to the screening
process that are intended to protect
both the visa applicant and the u.s.
petitioner for example if the American
petitioner used a foreign marriage
broker which are the companies that are
often referred to as mail-order bride
companies they have to disclose it to
the US government and the broker must
meet certain strict requirements not as
strict as building new housing in San
Francisco but still kind of onerous all
US petitioners must undergo a background
check and the results must be shared
with the immigrant fiance this helps
protect a foreign fiancee from arriving
in the United States to discover that
the American fiancee is a criminal and
they say screw green cards therefore for
people that get over here
US law also mandates that if a
petitioner has committed specific
violent or sex crimes they cannot
petition for a k1 visa these are crimes
like homicide stalking assault domestic
violence kidnapping and human
trafficking and what about if the
foreign fiancee has a criminal record
well if the fiancee has a criminal
record in most cases the person will be
ineligible for the visa or to enter the
United States at all this is even true
when the person's crimes have been
expunged even misdemeanor convictions
can make a person ineligible these
crimes are listed in Section 212 of the
Immigration and Nationality Act they
include crimes of moral turpitude a
violation of any drug law u.s. are
foreign any kind of drug trafficking
even if it doesn't result in a
conviction prostitution or participating
in prostitution in any way participating
in human trafficking whether directly or
indirectly and money laundering now
there are some exceptions to the rules a
person may apply for a waiver of a drug
offense if it was a single offense of
simple possession of marijuana and if
the conviction was over 15 years old
before applying for the visa but the US
has to be satisfied that the person was
rehabilitated the person seeking the
waiver also has to show that admission
to the US would not be contrary to the
national welfare safety or security of
the United States if you're overseas
fiance was convicted of only one crime
in
maximum penalty possible for that crime
is less than one year he or she might
not need the waiver of inadmissibility
this exception does not take into
account the actual sentence length given
to the person but rather the maximum
penalty that could have been given as a
result of the crime the sentencing
exception does not apply however to drug
crimes
now the 90-day fiance has several
different couples impacted by one
person's criminal history let's take a
look at the situation for Tiffany and
Ronald from ninety-day the other way
Tiffany is an American who went to South
Africa and fell in love with Ronald
Ronald turned out to have a pretty
serious history of gambling I was at my
rock bottom
I had a full-blown addiction of gambling
he has been charged with armed robbery
theft and possession of drugs during a
traffic stop and Ronald's addiction was
so bad that he wound up selling off his
mother's kitchen appliances got arrested
and the adjudication was delayed so he
could attend rehab Tiffany who wasn't
even fully aware of the full extent of
Ronald's issues moved with her son
Daniel to South Africa once she learned
the truth she decided to marry Ronald
anyway and the two tied the knot just
days after he moved out of rehab when
Tiffany got pregnant she decided she
couldn't stand living in South Africa so
she returned to the US now where does
this leave Ronald her drug and gambling
addicted husband his records a little
funky there's quite a bit on there well
at the most recent tell-all Tiffany
announced that she is starting the
process to bring Ronald to the US on a
spousal visa when she discussed this
with a lawyer on an earlier episode the
lawyer explained that Ronald's arrest
history would be problematic for him to
come to the United States even without
an actual conviction if there's anywhere
in his record that he admitted it that
is an admission for which he can be
determined in admissible Tiffany however
feels confident that this history won't
matter because she erroneously believed
that love is stronger than lawyers but
in this particular instance Tiffany
might be right violations of gambling
laws are not generally considered crimes
of moral turpitude
Ronald's other charges could present
problems however especially the drug
charge the USCIS will have to review the
full extent of his South African arrests
before they decide if he can come to
United States now the show also includes
couples who are already
married people who married a foreign
spouse can apply for a CR 1 visa to
allow them to immigrate to America
people who apply for the CR 1 must
satisfy most the same requirements as
the k1 visa including a clean criminal
record and proving that they have
financial support now traditionally it
was easy to bring a foreign-born spouse
to America however that has changed in
recent years largely due to the Trump
administration's travel ban the travel
ban restricts immigration from countries
deemed dangerous including Iran Libya
Somalia Syria Yemen North Korea and
Venezuela we've already seen how this
plays out in the show a 19 year old
Avery was a self-described party girl
from Columbus Ohio until she met Omar a
Syrian online the two fell in love and
she converted to Islam and Avery married
Omar on a trip to Lebanon this means she
didn't need to apply for a k1 fiancee
visa and although Avery's mother kind of
sort of supports the relationship oh my
gosh she is highly uncomfortable with
the idea of her daughter moving to Syria
to live with Omar even though he insists
that this part of Syria is pretty safe
the whole country is in the middle of
civil war entry I personally think
you're worrying too much
eventually the couple decided that the
best thing would be for Omar to come to
the u.s. so they applied for the cr1
visa which is for an immigrant spouse
unfortunately for the couple the travel
ban restricts the number of Syrians who
can enter the u.s. even if they are
married to an American citizen the
lawyer has worked on he said many travel
ban cases and none of them have been
approved a cr1 visa is supposed to be
easy to obtain but the Supreme Court
okayed the travel ban in part because
the Trump administration said it would
grant waivers if a couple experienced
undue hardship and the foreign spouse
was basically not a terrorist in
practice though the waiver has been
harder to obtain the Trump
administration has been vague about what
constitutes an undue hardship according
to the Trump administration fewer than
5% of people who applying for waivers
have been approved and of this five
percent who were approved the government
is in no rush to provide the visas over
one third of those who have been
approved are still awaiting the visa
that's why some are finding their spouse
and admit
trait of limbo instead of being denied
the the case is placed in administrative
processing where it may sit for many
years and although avery and omar have
indicated that Omar's application was
accepted that just means the government
is reviewing the petition to enter the
country as a lawyer explained to Avery
Omar is going to need that waiver if he
has any hope of getting into the United
States now admittedly lots of ninety-day
fans are claiming the TLC told that
lawyer to lie about Omar's hopes of
getting into United States but the
lawyer is probably right here as the
form shows Omar's petition has been
accepted for processing but it says
right on the bottom of the form that it
is not a visa it will still be an uphill
battle for him to be admitted now there
are limitations on the k1 visa a person
who enters the u.s. has 90 days to marry
a US citizen but only that particular US
citizen if a guy likes engine from the
new season of 90 days decides that tanya
is not really his cup of tea and he'd
rather marry another American he will
have to leave the country and start the
whole process all over again and it
looks like American citizen Rebecca
from before the 90 days is on her second
k1 visa Rebecca was in the middle of a
divorce from her moroccan born husband
when she met Syed a 26 year old from
Tunisia amazing Rebecca who is a private
investigator has now applied for the k1
visa for zayeed and she better make this
one count since a US citizen is limited
to two k1 visas during their entire
lifetime this limitation protects
foreign fiancees from exploitation
because if a US citizen could apply for
k1 visas whenever they felt like it they
could lure people into the country with
false promises of marriage and then
subject that person to involuntary
servitude or worse and although
Rebecca's Moroccan ex hasn't appeared on
the show his legal status could be up in
the air because of their divorce the
immigration fraud Amendments of 1986
make the foreign spouses permanent
residency conditional for two years this
means that the couples must remain
married for two years for the visa to
stick if the couple splits up then the
government may revoke the immigrant
spouses permanent residency
status this means that the person is in
the country unlawfully and has to leave
of course there are lots of procedural
hurdles that can trip up a visa
application on the brand-new season of
90 day fiancé we met Michael and Juliana
Michael is a 42 year old quote wine
entrepreneur and Juliana is a 23 year
old Brazilian model when they met at a
yacht party in Croatia when Juliana was
about 19 years old it was love at first
sight again I don't necessarily believe
in love at first sight but it's like we
were kindred spirits
although Michael flew around the world
with Juliana she was repeatedly denied a
u.s. visitor visa the reason her age and
history were red flags for prostitution
the US government can deny entry to any
person who it suspects is coming to the
United States solely principally or
incidentally to engage in prostitution
or has engaged in prostitution within
ten years of the date of the application
for a visa admission or adjustment of
status Juliana and Michael vehemently
deny that Juliana was ever an escort or
a yacht girl Michael stresses that
Giuliana was just a beautiful girl from
a very poor village in Brazil who found
love in a not so hopeless place a yacht
full of rich people certainly a lot of
people that may pass judgment may think
I'm just an old sleazy rich guy going
after a young hot woman it doesn't
bother me at all but not surprisingly
these are the very things that the
government considers red flags you don't
need to be convicted of prostitution to
be denied entry in practice the
government is looking carefully at
people who are working in the tourism or
entertainment industries sometimes
there's a very fine line between being a
model and being a model who is also paid
to entertain clients on a boat for
example let's talk about you
what do you do for a living madam the
model what kind of model shows the
government is also actively screening
for victims of human trafficking
although Juliana and Michael protests
the questions over their motives teen
girls from Brazil and Thailand are often
lured into dangerous situations by men
promising lucrative modeling
opportunities and unfortunately escort
jobs can sometimes be the gateway or the
price
of admission to working in entertainment
and tourism of course Michael claims
that he has already invested more than a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
his relationship with Juliana
there didn't seem to be much due process
Michael whined in the second episode
which focused on Giuliana's interview
with the US immigration authorities
Michael and Juliana have a lawyer so I'm
willing to bet that they were well aware
that this question would continue to pop
up but don't take my word for it just
look at this form the i-485 application
for the k1 visa as you can see question
35 36 37 and 38 all concerned
allegations of prostitution and despite
the probing questions eventually the
government decided that Juliana had not
in fact been involved in illicit
activities now many ninety-day fans have
questions about another potential legal
hurdle to the k1 visa immigrants from
countries where polygamy is legal so
let's see how this plays out thanks to
the ever popular couple Michael and
Angela Angela was a divorced grandmother
of six when she met Michael a trump
loving 30 year old Nigerian man online
Angela's first visit to Nigeria was
featured on before the 90 days she was
going to propose to Michael but then she
discovered that he committed some let's
say unusual sexual indiscretions at a
nightclub but the relationship was off
or was it the two spent the rest of the
season fighting Angela accused Michael
of taking from her bank account without
authorization and broke off the
engagement
later Angela figured out it was banking
error and Michael was back in but on the
next season Angela and Michael renewed
their engagement they have applied for a
k1 visa but there may be trouble ahead
the 58 year old grandmother has promised
Michael and his mom that she will have
his baby
as soon as possible a fertility doctor
said Angela is down to her very last egg
so Angela hit up her daughter for a
fresh one Angela's daughter has
repeatedly refused to give her mother an
egg so Michael has proposed having a
baby with another woman and in certain
areas of Nigeria polygamy is in fact
legal which brings us to the question
what happens if polygamy is legal in
foreign country could Michael bring
another Nigerian spouse into the country
on a k1 visa and then live happily ever
after with Angela and the other
wife well the answer is No although TLC
would dearly love to have a reality show
called my big fat polygamist fiancees
polygamy is illegal in the United States
and a person cannot emigrate or become a
naturalized US citizen if they practice
polygamy Angela and Michael will need to
resort to plan B if anyone has a free
egg remember she can tote it
she just needs the egg egg of course the
most important requirement for a k1 visa
is something you won't find in the US
Code what all of these 90-day fiance is
have in common is that they are all
Instagram experts it's pretty much a
requirement for entry to the US these
days now if you want to be a 90-day
fiance or at least raise your Instagram
game I'd highly recommend Brandon
waffles Skillshare class
instagram-worthy photography shoot edit
and share you can go behind the scenes
as Brandon shares his full process for
capturing one-of-a-kind portraits and
action shots every step is packed with
helpful tips and unexpected hacks
developed over Brandon's journey from
teaching himself photography in his
bedroom to inspiring over 3 million
followers on Instagram Skillshare is an
online learning community that has
thousands of classes on everything like
lifestyle music design technology and
business it's great for brazillian
fiance's who just want to come to the US
and party on boats a yearly membership
is less than $10 per month but legal
eagles will get two free months of
Skillshare when you click on the link
below plus it really helps out the
channel so just click on the link below
the free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must know topics so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things all free for two months so
make 2020 the year that you explore new
skills deepen existing passions and get
lost in your creativity with skill
shares online classes do you agree leave
your objections in the comments and
check out my other real law reviews over
here where I talk about whistleblowers
hearsay objections and the impeachment
inquiry tons and tons of other legal
breaking news and as always I'll see you
in court